the modern world is deeply attracted to
ancient Greece every year around 1
million people visit the Parthenon and
wander around the ruins because they're
sure the place and the culture of which
its supreme embodiment has something
important to say to them but it's often
not quite clear what what can H and
Greece do for us it's a big Volga but
central question there are perhaps five
big ideas we can take away from ancient
Greece the Greeks thought it was
extremely important for everyone
regularly to witness a certain sort of
gory tale they called a tragedy
festivals existed to honor these
tragedies and governments closed Civic
buildings businesses and law courts to
enable citizens to go and see them some
festivals such as the festival of
Dionysus in Athens which began in 508 BC
would last a week and involve up to 17
plays famous plays included Aeschylus as
the Auris tyre Sophocles is Ajax eater
puss the king and Electra and Euripides
is Madea in these tragedies people were
seen to break a minor law or make a
hasty decision or sleep with the wrong
person and the result was ignominy and
death yet what happened was shown to be
to a large extent in the hands of what
the Greeks called fate or the gods it
was the Greeks poetic way of saying the
things often work out in random ways
according to dynamics that simply don't
reflect the merits of the individuals
concerned in the poetics the philosopher
Aristotle defined the key ingredients of
tragedy the hero of the tragedy should
be a decent person better than average
often highborn but prone to making small
mistakes as we all do at the start it
may not be obvious that it is an error
they are making but by an unfortunate
chain of events for which they are not
wholly to blame this small mistake leads
to a catastrophe
tragedy is the sympathetic morally
complex account of how good people can
end up in disastrous situations it's the
very opposite of today's tabloid
newspaper or social media sphere whether
mob rushes to make judgments on those
who've slipped out Aristotle thought it
was extremely important that people see
tragic works
on a regular basis to counter their
otherwise strong inclinations to charge
and moralize tragedy is meant to be a
corrective to easy judgment without the
idea of tragedy we can make existence
for everyone far crueler and far more
judgmental than it really need be we
should look back to the Greeks to
recover an extremely important idea
Athens was the cradle of philosophy home
of the three greatest philosophers
Socrates Plato and Aristotle what unites
the Greek philosophers is a search for
what they termed eudaimonia which
translators happiness or fulfillment
they saw philosophy as a hugely
practical subject that could help people
find their way through the dilemmas of
life the approach was already contained
in the word philosophy itself in Greek
filo means love or devotion and Sophia
means wisdom philosophers were people
devoted to wisdom though a bit abstract
the concept of wisdom isn't mysterious
being wise means attempting to live and
die well leading as good a life as
possible within the troubled conditions
of existence what we call the history of
Greek philosophy is made up of repeated
attempts over the centuries to address
ways in which we are unwise so for
example Socrates paid special attention
to the problem of how people get
confused in their minds he was struck
that people didn't quite know what they
meant by key ideas like courage or
justice or success even though these
were the main ideas they used when
talking about their own lives socrates
developed a method which still bears his
name by which you can learn to get
clearer about what you mean by playing
devil's advocate with any idea the aim
isn't necessarily to change your mind
it's to test whether the ideas guiding
your life are sound a few decades later
the philosopher Aristotle tried to make
us more confident around big questions
he thought the best questions were those
that ask what something is for he did
this a lot and over many books asking
what is government for what is the
economy for what's money for what's art
for today he might be encouraging us to
ask questions like what's the news media
for what's marriage for what's
pornography for also active in ancient
Greece with a stoic philosophers who
were interested in panic
the Stoics noticed a really central
feature of panic we panic not just when
something bad occurs but when it does so
unexpectedly when we were assuming that
everything was going to go rather well
so they suggested that we should arm
ourselves against panic by getting used
to the idea that danger trouble and
difficulty are very likely to occur at
every turn the overall task of studying
Greek philosophy is to a
absorb these and many other lessons and
put them to work in the world today the
point isn't just to know what this will
that philosopher happened to say but to
aimed exercise wisdom at an individual
and societal level starting now
Athens is known as the home of democracy
democracy was developed in the fifth
century BC first under Solon
then Cleisthenes and Ephialtes however
democracy came under threat in the later
stages of the fifth century BC when
Athens was in the myths of fighting a
lengthy war with its nemesis Sparta the
Peloponnesian War so to remind Athenians
of their importance within a democracy
the great general Pericles delivered a
rousing speech at the annual funeral
oration to mark the dead of the war in
430 BC what makes Pericles his famous
speech so striking is that he isn't
defending democracy just as a way of
running the state he's defending what we
might call the democratic spirit a
spirit of equality community and
comradeship that can develop in
societies where members more or less
feel themselves to be equal to one
another the voting system is a route to
something much deeper that we might term
fellow feeling and emotion the Greeks
discovered for Humanity Pericles
declared the administration of Athens
favors the many instead of the few this
is why it's called a democracy if we
look to the laws they have fought equal
justice to all in their private
differences if there is no social
standing advancement in public life
Falls to reputation for capacity class
considerations not being allowed to
interfere with merit nor again does
poverty by the way if a man is able to
serve the state he is never hindered by
the obscurity of his condition against
the brutality of the Spartans Pericles
celebrates the generosity erudition
openness public spiritedness and dignity
of Athenian democratic life these values
Pericles says enables Athens to provide
a shining beacon of freedom and decency
to the Greek world and now to our own
times two
the Greeks were architects par
excellence they were involved in the
construction of five of the seven
wonders of the ancient world the temple
of artemis at ephesus statue of zeus at
olympia the mausoleum at halicarnassus
the colossus of rhodes and the
lighthouse of alexandria but the most
common inspiring buildings with our
ordinary temples magnificent structures
typically made of limestone and
scattered all across Greece in its
islands aside from the temples on the
Acropolis other great structures include
the temple of apollo at corinth the
temple of zeus at olympia and the temple
of poseidon at suny on the architectural
language of these temples has spread
around the world even when their
specific religious uses have fallen by
the wayside because they suggest values
which humanity will always find
impressive harmony dignity calm reason
the Greeks taught the West how to build
in such a way that would externalize
some of the noblest ideals of human
beings where earlier civilizations such
as the Egyptians Persians and Assyrians
found nakedness shameful the Greeks
celebrated the naked body of both gods
and citizens works such as the Zeus or
Poseidon of Artemis Aeon shows the
stature power and physical prowess of a
nude Greek god
disco bolus shows the action of a naked
discus throw a midpoint physical beauty
of an athlete his muscles perfectly
toned the Greeks loved physical exercise
there was at least one major national
athletic competition every year the most
famous sporting event was the Olympic
Games held every four years from 776 BC
but what's distinctive in the Greek
approach is that they didn't want
athletes merely to be athletes the idea
was that everyone should train both mind
and body it's telling that Milo of
Croton a celebrated wrestler of the 6th
century BC was also an associate of the
great mathematician Pythagoras one of
the important Greek mantras was that a
healthy mind could only dwell in a
healthy body the Greeks thought exercise
conditioned discipline in people which
would enable them to be diligent and
virtuous democratic citizens in Athens
or devote and controlled warriors in
Sparta ancient Greek gyms were nothing
like the mindless body pumping places of
our own times they were both public
centres for physical train
and intellectual hubs gymnasia and
schools were simply the same thing a
great number of Socrates's dialogues
about ideas around justice and truth
unfold
tellingly at the gym we owe to the
Greeks the remarkable now often
forgotten idea that our bodies should be
looked after just as our minds are and
that for someone to be merely an
intellectual or merely a bodybuilder is
obscene true virtue means a balance
between the physical and the mental
there is a sad morality tale about the
end of ancient Greek civilization they
had much nicer ideas than their enemies
but they weren't as well organized
so they got defeated and the ideas got
lost for centuries the Greek city-states
fought among themselves endlessly over
the course of the 5th and 4th centuries
BC and were eventually stripped of their
independence under Alexander the Great
the Greeks failed to add political
stability to their virtues the ideas of
Greece no longer survive in the country
in which they first originated but it
should be attributed to ancient Greece
that the best of these ideas remain of
complete relevance to our own times with
the help of the Greeks we need to
remember the role of tragedy emphasized
the practice of philosophy honor the
spirit of democracy build with harmony
and dignity and exercise both mind and
body in equal measure for all this we
can be grateful to the now absent Greeks
as we wander among the rubble of the
Parthenon if you like our films take a
look at our shop the School of Life comm
forward slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you